yo what up my name is Christina Elmore
and I'm playing condolence and I've been
playing Lawrence for for Susan that's
right been amazing okay I feel like men
are often called like petty or trifling
or like childish whatever because they
can't either forgive or they can't move
on or they can't just have friendships
with their exes right and I feel like
Lawrence has that with ISA it's a
friendship yes of course it's a little
bit awkward that his friend ISA is also
friends and working with his girlfriend
condolence is the problem she like
drives though she brings she makes it
the thing
more's doesn't make it the things do you
think could Dola makes it the thing yes
so when Lawrence comes into that kitchen
and he says I feel like you're not over
your eggs and Lawrence hasn't really
gotten over its population at least it
seems that way to condole it yeah but
canola hasn't really gotten over her
past relationship either condole along
let herself ever get married again
because she was married but there's the
present-day issue at hand that we have
not reconciled yes this is an issue even
if it's a current live action issue I
don't know if even the motorists of the
mature can handle working with becoming
friends with a woman a lot it's a lot
talking about him telling you all the
little things he does and you laugh at
them because you're like oh I've seen
him do that too and y'all there still
have an inside jokes and haha but I
can't get in well good I guess we just
gotta wait and see what happens
cuz they don't tell us nothing y'all
they don't we don't know we don't know
we just show up and read they don't
you